hi everybody this is done Walker I'm
here at Matsuri conda's my second year
here it's an anime con and something
really cool as I'm here with Kyle a bear
oh my gosh that's right and the great
thing about Kyle a bear if you don't
know is that he is actually the narrator
of Dragon Ball Z even if you don't watch
anime
you probably heard the narrator of
Dragon Ball Z and he's gonna do a little
bit of the voice right now absolutely
next time on dragon ball z dokkan super
saiyan met sri context over Columbus
Ohio and then Goku even tries hmm
Mountain Dew it doesn't stop there
breezes attacking self attacking margin
boos attacking whoa the world is going
to be destroyed in less than 60 seconds
and then Goku watches TMZ he's followed
around by paparazzi it won't stop it
just won't stop and then Lady Gaga wears
a meat suit can the meat suit stop all
the Super Saiyans this is actually I'm
incredible he's been going for like 20
minutes it's really wick he's like
really dedicated to that guy ooh la la
Oh cosplayers are all out there like
zombies
in fact descent is in the air okay he's
been going out for like an hour this is
actually kind of scary I'm Mel
legitimately players it's ugly
it's scary I see people that shouldn't
be cosplaying in Salus out uniform you
need to stop Super Saiyans and
defeat rule Marvin Dent can he be
trusted Americans no no in the rise of a
Planet of the Apes Hail Caesar okay Kyle
you've been really great I am too Brutus
you really need to stop now I don't know
this is way too long I am concerned for
you that the buyer beware
okay well I gotta go now there's lots of
things I need to do I'm just gonna very
slowly back away from you right now
apocalypse army wonderful fantastic okay
that was weird I don't know what that
guy is on but he is freakin dedicated
like he is our state plan but they don't
often work not in the time of an
emergency like the apocalypse
the elevators take a long time they take
an extremely long time but will it stop
ever really aliens
of course the elevators full of people
but will it be enough to stop the threat
of the alien menace
artists full of art art art the alien
threat from beyond trying to buy
something go away the threat is your
table keeps on to go away shut up shut
up you you shut up God you must shut up
he just keeps going and going and going
these like a deranged energizer bunny
you want shut up shut up
alright so my first question for you is
how did you come up with the idea for
the guy with moustache back out it
really started out at first you know I
was there okay she'sa think god I think
I need to die next time on Dragon Ball Z
bother
Kyle a bear is an asshole if you will
not shut up here follow me everywhere
everywhere throughout this goddamn cons
doing this stupid voice I'm gonna doodle
right now look he will not shut up your
anus your anus
hey who would rather hear me or some
idiot do the narration for Dragon Ball Z
next time on Dragon Ball see yo I didn't
real really fucking hate my fans right
now
don't touch me next thing you know
trunks comes in with his sword can he
actually pull up the sword this huge you
can totally shove it in there two men
three men for Super Saiyans will they
have what it takes to defeat the alien
menace and beyond the stars find out on
the next exciting episode
okay so I just killed a man
chances are I'm gonna see you guys and
ten to 20 but there was some way I could
blame this on someone else
hey Eric Vale coming up
all right we're those free hookers that